[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american fantasy
drama film called wendy
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie starts in darling's diner
owned by a middle-aged woman named
angela darling she has three kids two
twin sons james and douglas and a
younger daughter wendy their diner lies
right by a railroad in the rural south
and is always filled with people it is a
happy and lively place where everybody
loves little wendy one day a little guy
named thomas marshall is in the diner
enjoying a meal for his seventh birthday
his grandmother jokes that he will be a
cleaner at the diner when he grows up
thomas retaliates he wants to be a
pirate but the seniors just laugh at him
overwhelmed with emotions he walks
outside when no one is watching little
wendy who is some years younger than
thomas crawls towards the window and
watches as he gets on a moving train
there seems to be another child on the
train with him whose face isn't clearly
seen
time passes and wendy gets older but she
never forgets what she saw that day she
becomes more imaginative with time and
often writes her own bedtime stories
about adventures at only nine years old
she has a thirst for adventure and is
willing to take risks for a rush of
adrenaline as wendy helps her mother and
brothers at the diner we see a notice on
a board that says thomas disappeared at
the age of 7 and has never been found
along with another 13 year old boy
indicating that children go missing
frequently in the town wendy is calm and
composed in contrast to her brothers who
are always dancing singing and making
noise the four of them are a happy
family nonetheless one night on the
boy's demand their mother tells them a
bedtime story about her life she claims
that she was wild when she was younger
and had dreams and aspirations that
people would make fun of her for
she once hitchhiked to california and
stole cars on her way wendy thinks it's
cool that her mom's a criminal and asks
her what her dreams are now angela
replies that she wants to take care of
her children she adds that as people get
older and things change their dreams
also change this makes wendy sad because
she never wants to give up her dream of
going on several adventures and she
doesn't want to get old either the
following day after school the kids go
to a canal to fish james and douglas are
busy when wendy runs towards the railway
tracks she sees a train and chases
behind it hoping to board it as thomas
did years ago but she falls along the
way and misses it while returning home
she remembers her brother's words your
life will go by and nothing will ever
happen
at night everyone is asleep but wendy
keeps herself busy by making up stories
about stars
suddenly a mysterious red light passes
through the window and the sound of a
train approaching is heard she looks
outside the window and sees a boy
playing and running on top of a moving
train
it is the same little boy named peter
who was with thomas when he disappeared
wendy wakes her brothers up and climbs
out of the window to get a closer look
the boys follow behind her but cannot
stop her before she jumps on the train
they too get on board following their
sister wendy spreads her arms feeling
free for the first time
then they are approached by a laughing
peter the guys ask him what their stop
is but peter replies that there are no
stops because this is an adventure
in the morning peter tells wendy that
the world has no end it goes on and on
forever past the restaurants and the
houses peter is a flat earther when they
reach above a river peter asks them to
line up on the edge of the train the
kids do it without asking any questions
and yell in fear when they are pushed
into the river by him peter jumps behind
them and introduces them to a kid on a
boat all of them get on the boat and
sail to the sea eventually reaching a
volcanic tropical island a fish-like
creature from the sea makes a noise that
peter claims is the mother welcoming
them
seeing the magical island wendy
remembers the voice in her head that
used to ask her to sneak into the night
she figures that the noise has been
coming from the island all along an
active volcano is shooting out smoke in
the air indicating the magical charge of
the place peter runs into the woods with
his friend making the siblings follow
them on their way they are terrorized by
smoke coming out of the ground a while
later they meet a guy their age singing
a melody to the big volcano wendy joins
him out of nowhere peter approaches them
and says that their singing was hopeless
he meditates and performs some hand
gestures of his own triggering the
volcano the others run away in fear and
excitement suddenly a little boy comes
running their way who wendy recognizes
as thomas although he was older than her
when he ran away he doesn't seem to have
aged a day
upon inquiry thomas claims that he is a
blackbeard and runs away at night the
other kids play and laugh around the
confused darling siblings
eventually they join the others and
start singing the same melody from
earlier when they wake up the next
morning peter is looking at the sea
claiming that he is talking to the
mother later he and wendy jump into a
pit on the ground and reach a canal
peter takes her into the sea and shows
her the mother who turns out to be the
island's spirit in the form of a massive
fish that spreads a golden glow wherever
it goes
peter explains that when the first child
laughed for the first time the mother
rose up to the surface from the center
of the earth to watch over them she
preserves their childhood so they can go
on any adventure and do whatever they
want for as long as they like however
the magic only works if you maintain
faith in the mother if someone stops
believing in her they will age at an
exponential rate and turn old for the
next few days life is like a movie for
the children they play dance sing and
laugh from day to night without any care
douglas and james completely forget
about their mother back home but wendy
thinks to herself that she is just
extending her visit and will return home
once she is done having fun
one day wendy wakes up to see an elderly
man wandering close by
when she greets him he runs off into a
barren side of the island the children
explain his name is buzzo a former
member of their group who lost faith in
mother when he lost his best friend and
so aged into an old man
after that they find a capsized boat
called the manana in the sea the darling
siblings swim to the boat to inspect it
douglas is skeptical about swimming into
the compartments of the ship but he
agrees when james calls him a coward the
three dive into the compartment but only
james and wendy emerge from the other
side worried for douglas they dive back
inside but are unable to find him the
other kids also help them look but are
unsuccessful eventually they drag their
brother and sister out of the water
assuring them that douglas must be fine
because he was his twin this affects
james the most when he wakes up the next
day his hand has wrinkled and turned old
wendy realizes that james has lost faith
in the mother and asks her to keep it a
secret from the others however peter
soon finds out about it james tries to
snatch peter's sword to cut off his old
arm in order to stop the aging process
peter volunteers to do it himself and
cut his arm wendy runs to her brother
who falls to the ground in pain she
angrily asks everyone to get away from
them and takes james with her in search
of an actual adult they come across
buzzo who agrees to help them he puts
james on a donkey and takes the two to
the old people's quarter it is the place
where all the children who have turned
into old people live everyone there is
catching and killing fishes which
confuses wendy she inquires what they
are doing only to find out that eating
the mother will give old people their
childhood back so they are trying to
catch her
james's arm is now tied in a cloth and
has stopped bleeding to rest he and
wendy go to an abandoned diner with the
other old people
silence prevails in the room until wendy
asks everyone to bring their childhood
spirits back even if they are old she
dances urging the others to do the same
eventually all of them get together and
dance except for james who is still very
depressed he runs out in frustration as
wendy follows him james goes to the
fishing zone and gets the nets ready the
other old people see this and decide to
make him their leader because he knows
how to fish james comes out with another
plan to capture the mother he suggests
they abduct the children which will make
the mother come to them herself wendy
retaliates against the idea but the
others like it they start to prepare to
kidnap the kids while wendy runs back to
the woods to alert them but the adults
get there before her and kidnap all the
children
the only one that could hide and save
himself is peter wendy joins him and the
two watch the adults repair the boat
manana and board the kids onto it wendy
notices a man with only one arm bending
a hook it turns out that the man is
james who has grown into an adult after
they sail away with the boat peter urges
wendy to come with him and save their
friends they jump into the ocean and end
up in the canal again
there peter tells wendy about his family
back home wendy wanders off to the other
side of the canal to find douglas alive
and well the two reunite and set off to
look for their friends on a rowboat
seeing no one on the deck the three of
them climb up to the boat and try to
untie the children but the adults catch
them and bring them to their leader
james he has now turned fully old and
has a hook in place of his missing arm
james and douglas are both surprised to
see each other james is mad at him for
staying young while he turned old while
douglas refuses to believe james is his
brother suddenly the sound of the mother
is heard the adults all prepare to hunt
her while the kids beg them to stop they
free themselves and jump into the water
to get the mother out of the net but are
too late as james strikes her with a
harpoon and injures her gravely the
golden glow from the mother's body
disperses and drops to the bottom of the
ocean james manages to get a piece of
flesh from the mother's body but at last
refuses to eat it peter cries in vain
about losing the mother and wendy
comforts him by hugging him he is
worried that he will now get old and die
now even making the seniors feel bad for
the kid
wendy assures all of them that their
story is great and the bigger they get
the more stories they can form
they can get married and have children
who will have stories of their own hence
they should not be disheartened she then
gets them all to start singing the
melody again as their singing grows
louder peter becomes more inspired and
the volcano erupts once more wendy and
douglas decide it is time for them to go
home
knowing that he cannot go home james
says his last goodbye to his twin he
then changes his name to captain hook
and stays to play with peter as his new
enemy thereby allowing him to live out
the rest of his days with the spirit of
a child in the ending monologue wendy
says that she douglas and the other
children have returned home to their own
families they have many adventures as
they grow older they dance and sing and
have fun even as adults many years later
wendy is now a mother with her own
daughter she tells the story of peter
and the island to her as a bedtime story
her daughter says that mystery recapped
tells stories better at night while
wendy sleeps her daughter hops on the
train with peter wendy runs after but
she cannot catch up to them she then
watches them get away with a smile on
her face knowing that her daughter is in
good hands and is ready for an adventure
of her own the moral of the story is
that getting kidnapped builds character
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching